hi there Steve here today I want to talk
about getting started in a new language
I think when we start in a new language
we're starting from very often zero
knowledge in my case I'm gonna refer to
Farsi which has been my latest sort of
new language but it's an experience
obviously that I've had with many
languages Farsi is particularly
difficult for a few reasons that I'll
explain but the process is the same and
if anything my approach to new languages
is becoming refined so Farsi difficult
because it's written in the Arabic
alphabet and while I have now gotten
somewhat used to the Arabic alphabet in
learning Arabic it's still difficult
it's always easiest to learn in your own
alphabet second of all on link or
whatever the whatever we use for
text-to-speech it's not available for
Farsi so I can't click on a word and
hear it that's a bit of a problem so how
do I and third of all I would say I
haven't given up on Arabic I am
continuing to work on my Arabic and I'm
kind of dividing my time depending on my
mood of the day between Arabic and farsi
when I find a Farsi too difficult I get
back I go back to Arabic and of course
it's much easier and I feel good about
myself when I'm in need a bit of a
challenge I go back to Farsi why am i
learning Farsi because there's far more
opportunity to use Farsi here in West
Vancouver North Vancouver my doctor is
from Iran storekeepers from Iran lots of
people from Iran not so many people from
Arabic country countries and of course
when you get into a language you start
reading about that country so I'm
reading about the Persian Empire 500 BC
Darius Cyrus Xerxes or however it's
pronounced and then all that kind of
stuff Battle of Marathon and so forth so
now what do I do
okay first of all I have found over the
years as I get into new
images that it's it's very good to start
with almost low intermediate content not
to start with absolutely simple content
and therefore to go at these more or
less intermediate type content low
intermediate type content with a lot of
repetition so what I do with Farsi is
because at link we can have we can view
the whole text or we can go sentence by
sentence so I tend to I have started a
new sort of process which I think it's
quite good so you'll see that I'm
working with the mini stories and I'm
gonna give you a series of screenshots
here I tried to record myself using it
on the website and off my iPad and I
really couldn't make it work in any
satisfactory way so I'm gonna use a few
screenshots if I get better at recording
you know myself using it I will do so if
there's interest so I'm working with a
mini story series I've gone through sort
of the first ten saving words and
phrases listening to it and more and
more words that I start to pick up I've
heard it heard them many many times but
so if I go to a new lesson let's say
less than 13 here where I have some
words that I have already encountered
before which are in yellow and then a
number of new words that are in blue one
thing that I found very useful to do is
to listen to the lesson while reading
the English translation now in the case
of the many stories in the case of who
is she some of the content that we have
in Farsi the English translation in fact
the translation into a number of
languages is available so I can listen
and I get sort of the gist of what it is
about
in fact because I've done these many
stories in Greek and in Arabic and then
Slovak and so forth I'm familiar with
the stories and you know if we talk
about compelling input when we're
starting in a language trying to
decipher the language you get the hang
of words and phrases is quite compelling
so I find that if
I can deal with content that's familiar
because the more familiar the content is
the better you can understand it even if
you don't have the words so I if I have
familiar content and I'm motivated to
try to get the hang of the language this
actually helps me so listening to the
Farsi while reading the English starts
to make the content even more familiar
so once I finished doing that then I go
back and I go into sentence mode and I
listen to the sentence and because I
don't have text-to-speech I can't click
on each word so therefore I listen to
the sentence and I can go back five
seconds and listen to it again so I
start to get the hang of how these words
are pronounced so once I've really
dissected one sentence then I go to our
activities where I can go through the
words that I have saved in whatever it
might be you know multiple choice or
just a flashcard reverse-flash card
review them and then I go to the next
sentence and here again I listen to the
sentence I save any words that I need I
listen to it again using the five-second
back to really get the hang of this and
then I go through the words and phrases
in the activities so in this way I am
sort of working my threat now that
doesn't mean that when I finish and and
don't forget that in the many stories
the vocabulary repeats so it's the same
story essentially twice with a different
person or a different tense and then a
bunch of questions that reuse the same
vocabulary and I find what I'm listening
I'm not able to read then the questions
are really the easiest to understand
because there's so much repetition so
once I go through these now I'm up to
done ten which I listened to in my car
were ever more or less kind of more or
less getting getting it's just becoming
gradually clearer and clearer so this is
how I start into a new language I've
been at it for two weeks I don't start
with you know how I mean yes how are you
all at your Thorat you learn some of the
basic greetings but to get
further into the language I find this
kind of sort of semi intermediate
content with a lot of repetition and
using some of the techniques that I just
described helps me make the language
less strange and the more the language
becomes familiar less strange this is
sort of this gradual process of getting
used to it
listening reading going through some
words and phrases and typically I prefer
to review my words and phrases just
after I encountered them in a context
because I do find that this sort of
meaning or definition divorced from any
context it is less meaningful so I don't
know if that makes sense
I'm sorry that I'm just using these
still shots if I can figure out
technically how to record myself
actually doing it on on our website I
will do that if there is interest thank
you for listening bye for now
[Music]